Queen Elizabeth is now expressing her
support for Prince Harry and Megan
Markel's decision to step back from
royal life now this follows the so
called crisis talks yesterday at her
estate Charlie d'Agata is at Buckingham
Palace with more on the story Charlie
what's the reaction there well there's
been some surprise not by the outcome
which many thought was inevitable but
surprised at the personal tone of the
Queen's statement the biggest family
crisis to hit the House of Windsor in
decades was never going to be resolved
inside of three hours but Harry and
Megan's request to step down as senior
members of the royal family has been
approved by the boss if reluctantly
following what the Queen described as
constructive discussions came an
unprecedented personal statement
offering her full support although we
would have preferred them to remain
full-time working members of the royal
family we respect and understand their
wish to live a more independent life as
a family while remaining a valued part
of my family but there will be a period
of transition where the couple will
split their time between Britain and
Canada megan is already there with baby
Archie a time to resolve with the Queen
calls complex matters like will Prince
Charles still chip in with financial
support
what does transatlantic security look
like and how exactly do they plan to be
financially independent
but what's telling in that statement is
it seemed personal from the heart of
Harry's grandmother the word family
appears seven times in the first two
paragraphs the Queen even referring to
the couple by name not just their royal
titles Ingrid Seward has authored books
on the Queen she's talking about Harry
as a grandmother she doesn't want to
lose him and she wants to help him and
she understands how difficult it is for
people marrying into the royal family
now we have learned this morning that
Megan did not take part in this meeting
via a conference call the couple decided
it wasn't necessary
for her to join in Anthony Charlie
d'Agata with the drama at Buckingham
Palace thanks Charlie
you